[Musique]
couvrez ce sein que je ne saurais voir
c'est la mésaventure qu'a vécu jasmin
alors qu'elle visitait le musée du
louvre avec sa soeur son mari et son
bébé ma petite lana cinq mois et demi
avait faim il n'y avait presque personne
dans la salle alors j'ai décidé la
nourrir ici la mère décide alors
d'alerter son enfant discrètement mais
très vite un agent de sécurité va lui
demander de se rhabiller les corps des
femmes n'ont pas être des corps sexué
par des fautes face à la polémique le
louvre a tenu à s'excuser et rappelant
les règles dans l'enceinte de son musée
le règlement de visite interdite
absolument pas d'allaiter dans les
salles cette dame a bien fait nous
écrire nous allons faire un rappel
général des consignes une mise au point
qui rassure grandement aphrodite alors
elle vous favorable à l'allaitement en
public
alors
alors est la même mais oui bah oui bah
c'est la question hall est ouverte il va
très bien c'est à dire au musée au bout
dit voilà tout voilà alors bagnell tu
sais pas quoi dire dormez nous dire ce
que j'ai à cette question l'âge mais non
et à la question pour l'allaitement en
public mais oui donc c'est un public la
même public c'est même le lot en
question
les adjointes il bien fait d'intervalle
là je dis non
alors mettez la place générale
a été la première c'est à dire à ton
l'allaitement public ben c'est pas écrit
en anglais avec mon public on a eu les
gars
je vous dire si vous dites passer des
onglets vous restez pas non il faut dire
cela c'est les anglais et lima non c'est
ce qui ce qui m'a gêné là c'est l'aspect
provocateur presque au loup via un
espace dédié et moi j'en ai un peu marre
qu'on tape sur les agents qui lui ont
interdit parce qu'il pensait que c'était
le règlement il est on dire aller
ailleurs etc et je trouve que dans son
témoignage est un peu de provocation les
agents il applique le règlement
et françois l'amouller c'est moi mais
remis des modalités sont les veilles
nepad en ligne sur julien très bien
continuer benhaim à refaire vous plaisez
en fait la moue mais franchement moi je
trouve que la première partie à faire
l'amour
nous n'avons pas la guerre
c'est kim c'est qu'ils les anglais alors
je vous dis si c'est clair non je suis
choqué que j'y parle de provocation en
quoi c'est une provocation de donner le
sein à son enfant ça veut dire quoi
parce qu'on voit un bout de sein c'est
une exhibition sexuelle c'est vrai tu
veux que les femmes se cachent pour
faire quelque chose de normal et naturel
je ne comprends même pas qu'on puisse
être contre ça et comme on l'a dit c'est
interdit par la loi d'interdire
l'allaitement en public donc cette
agence est scandaleuse ce qu'il a fait
d'ailleurs le louvre a condamné son
action ait parlé de provocation gym fait
honteux francona donc du coup vous allez
taper sur l'agent qui va se faire
engueuler les jolies femmes skipper il
faut arrêter à d'accord pour arrêter et
je ne parle pas de la ddt je parle du
témoignage les exhiber comme ça le
témoignage je trouve que jasmine alors
il écrit voilà
ce à quoi il ya quoi de
n'importe quoi problème guillaume ça
vous ne voulez pas je trouve plein de
côtoyer du coc vide à l'époque on vit
dans une société en société c'est à dire
qu'on essaie de tous faire
pour vivre ensemble comme le rendu fort
et a pas de trouble ont choqué bas
sortir un centre dans tout le monde
non seulement vous parlez pas sur les
images vous n'êtes pas dans l'émission
mais c'est ça qu'a laissé parler la
paire serbe si beaucoup y ait des gens
qui donnent envie c'est vrai que
j'entends des voix mais aussi
insupportable c'est insupportable ouais
si si elle n'a pas le choix évident ben
a laissé crever de faim il ya des
toilettes et tout peut faire deux mètres
ça va être un petit peu de coaching et
éviter sinon on fait ce qu'on veut il ya
les arrange et donc ça me dérange pas ça
me dérange
la question avait été un enfant quel
était le problème qu'est-ce qui est
qu'est-ce qui la dérangeait elle pour
faire de m elle l'a fait elle talent a
dit qu'elle avait besoin de lui faire
don à l'année soit parce qu'on donnait
trois grandes le gam allait mourir dans
les trois secondes non mais je vois pas
pourquoi des femmes de chine aux gars il
a raison il ya une vocation c'est une
bonne volée petits pas la peine pour
elle et c'est normal de faire ça n'est
pas la peine de lever la main les mecs
qui est vous devez démarrer votre
passeport si les anglais non
[Applaudissements]
oh
sur ce que voulait dire c'est dehors
alors oui alors ici les anglais alors
oui donc alors donc c'est les anglais à
vos annonay attendait là on est dans une
société on a nos téléphones h24 en main
avec des photos relativement sexuelle
même sur instagram et ouf on n'est pas
choqué de ça et là en fait les puritains
quand une femme donne à manger à son
nom mais quoi c'est ça la peur que le st
d'un côté ils te choque pas sur
instagram par contre mes parents ou dhr
ton fils je veux voir qu'est ce qu'il ya
comme truc qui peut tout autant et privé
paie photos sont prévus sur ton
téléphone là à leur public de films en
allemand craint ça fait un buzz moi
c'est pas du tout privé on est dans une
société qui n'est plus tout choquée par
la nudité et là c'est pas de la nudité
mathieu signe enfin voilà à l'été c'est
juste aller tester une maman qui donne à
manger à son bas avec un saint
maixent sexuelle du coup maintenant
c'est que tout le monde a compris ce que
j'ai dit mais par contre non je ne sais
pas les anglais s'est bâti suis pas là
pour
me reymond non moi je trouve qu'il faut
vraiment voir un problème assez les
anglais
les doutes et que c'est les anglais on a
vu les images je la mets pas un problème
c'est que si la personne sort un petit
peu son son téton pour donner à manger à
son enfant il faut vraiment à dérégler
pour y voir un truc vous regardez pas
maintenant de là chaque fois que j'ai vu
quelqu'un à l'été je tourne la tête je
regarde là je suis pas là en train de
regarder comme un sauvage là elle est au
louvre peut-être que c'est l'endroit
parce qu'après prend le bus ça va
marcher à va pas là étaient dans la rue
c'est pas interdit de faire don quoi ça
gêne on dit on dit où il faut que les
nanas lsa ya la piscine les seins nus
mais t'as pas droit d'allaiter
maintenant
mais on a quand même un spécialiste
mamère autour de la table
mais c'est vrai voilà on a la chance de
l'avoir
à castaldi alors c'est les anglais bien
évidemment mais je suis en vie mais moi
c'est moi pour s'amuser vous dites voilà
moi ça me gêne ce court ça regarde mais
elle parce que toi taylor baptisée
non mais quand je suis au restaurant
cantons sur un restaurant en train de
manger que et qui est une maman sans son
sens à table pour manger
koné
plaît énormément
[Rires]
j'aime avec qui tu bouffes décoller le
gaillard
[Rires]
laborde elle donnait un non mais oh
c'est quoi ça non attends louati
l'arrière mais attends un peu de respect
tient sa demie et c'est pas parce que tu
as été traumatisée par un thé nouveau ça
que tu dois des boutons aux autres et
vous aimez ça te dérange voilà ça veut
dire ça dure dix minutes
tu vas l'autre toilette cachette on
s'est tu sors tu sors tout dire enfin
avec moi le précieux tu vas pas aller
aux toilettes et si ya pas de toilettes
comment tu fais jamais de leur
calendrier est ce que quelqu'un peut se
rattraper à l'endroit n'y a pas de
toilettes il ya des endroits des lieux
publics où les batteurs est en jeu c'est
les anglais qui ont raison et d'ailleurs
il ya des rythmes ans
seulement paix lui son histoire
américaine à s'éclairer période si les
bears et de l'insolence et d'insolence à
cheval ip gars et je te dis tu
apprendras
gilbert d'aix et on peut
les envier fait parvenir de phase iib
daniels et in the french albert
elle regarde aller vélo jusqu'au bout
focus et
[Applaudissements]
les amplis
alors bon ami c'est pas l'argent ils
intérêt mais
on avait du coup vous avez un truc
[Applaudissements]
les chéri e giuly je paye toujours mes
dettes c'est bien mais pas vous
inquiéter elle sera honorée
c'est une facture raconte
donc cet été un pro détour d'un bosquet
à l'humour fait la nuit
mais excusez mon sens l'un des plus
beaux jardins
eu beau geste alors journée
[Rires]
autrement qu'en tant être choqué en plus
laissés inégale ce qu'il a fait lui donc
le débat est clos mais en plus certains
des plus gros j'ai alors hier il ya
quelqu'un qui ait empêché une demande de
mariage à disneyland aujourd'hui c'est
au louvre ont fait un des plus beaux
gestes du monde on se fait engueuler
mais par contre alors la drogue partout
ça dérange
un
petit peu jus avoir décalé les ont fait
d'être autre chose d'un côté passé
même chose y en a tellement peu et ça
c'est beau c'est quelqu'un qui se
bouffer le cul dans un bosquet
[Rires]
frontières d'achat net n'ont
fait la lune un ami
alors j'ai parlé de mettre le budget des
ménages
c'est une des plus belles choses
pourquoi est-ce que vous ne pense pas
comme toi
je n'ai pas dans l'émission
tu n'es pas dans l'émission arrête oui
gilles versier d'anglais daniel vous
dites n'importe quoi vous mélangez les
délits est un acte encore une fois
provost qui se regardaient même la photo
regardez les ils jubilent au louvre dans
la joie alors
qu'est ce qu'ils racontent des conneries
et coup ses bras elle a allaité galerie
richelieu exprès je vous dis qu'ils ont
fait ça exprès pour taper dos quand
datent les assauts doit céder
provocateur veut tomber prend la porte
c'est les pédales et des joueurs phares
vous n'êtes pas dans l'émission avec vos
moules débile vous parasiter ce que je
dis c'est vrai qu'elle n'est pas dans
l'émission
vous nous parler les gens ne vous entend
pas étoiles calme-toi mais c'est rien
mais cgt tout émoustillé par ce qu'il va
se passer dans
la provocation